so nancy pelosi is landed in taiwan
currently she has a whole bunch of
police surrounding her hotel i believe
it's the hyatt i'm only saying that
because there's photos of it happening
otherwise i suppose it'd be a security
issue china has vowed to encircle taiwan
and apparently they're performing live
fire drills surrounding the entire
island nation so things are certainly
getting spicy and i just got to say my
friends
nothing's going to happen i really doubt
anything i don't think china is going to
risk their economic position over nancy
pelosi but everybody's really worried
and they're wondering why it is that
nancy pelosi decided to do this mitch
mcconnell and 25 other republicans have
come out in support of her move
we've been talking about it because none
of us know exactly why she's she's going
there although many people are
speculating that's because she's
probably buying stock in this
semiconductor production company who's
gonna be moving to arizona and you know
i don't know that's that's her mo but i
don't know if that's actually the case
we'll we'll talk about it we'll get into
it and then we've got probably my
favorite story of the day donald trump
the other day endorsed eric
just eric
in missouri which eric we don't know
there are three and when reached for
comment his ca his office said the
endorsement speaks for itself
i i love this man i just you know the
irreverence is is exactly what i'm
talking about okay when i talk about
putting a 96-foot billboard of my
rooster on times square
you know our
rooster
you know that we're trying to have a
good time and just kind of you know give
people a laugh and then donald trump
does something like this on a major
primary day and
i can't imagine it was an accident that
you endorsed three people and and two of
the front-runners are both eric and they
both claim to have spoken to him on the
phone and been endorsed by him
i think trump is trolling people because
he's sitting there he's laughing and he
knows what he's doing so we'll talk
about that and uh
nancy pelosi's husband is going to be
arraigned for a dui so this should get
really really interesting a bunch of
other stories before we get started my
friends head over to timcast.com
become a member to support our work as a
member you get access to all the shows
that we're launching oh i shouldn't do
that
i i i should not open the website when i
because it's alive anyway go to
tempgus.com we got sales from the
inverted world we got cass castle's
first promo episode it's gonna be coming
up next week it's longer might actually
be like 40 minutes because we actually
do a tour of the house and explain you
know what's going on and you'll also get
access to the uncensored after hours tim
cast irl interview show which we'll have
up for you with all our guests at 11 p.m
tonight so smash that like button
subscribe to this channel share the show
with your friends joining us tonight we
have angela mcardle hey there thanks for
having me back pull that up a little bit
and uh do you want to introduce who you
are sure so my name is angela i am the
chair of the national libertarian party
that's what i do right on we've uh you
were on just not that long ago and it
was really interesting to hear about the
uh the mises caucus taking over the
libertarian party so should be
interesting as we talk about all the
primaries that are happening today big
ones carrie lake for instance yeah she's
going to win uh we got corey d'angelo's
hanging out
hey corey angela senior fellow at the
american federation for children last
time i was here with you guys it was two
years ago right before all the school
closures happened in march of 2020. i
think it was like two weeks before the
whole nation locked down so a lot has
happened on the education front uh since
the last time i was on republicans are
apparently up on the issue of education
for the first time in like what three
decades or something yeah basically for
the first time ever i mean just in 2017
gallup had democrats up by 19 percentage
points and i tweeted this out just a
little bit ago and for the first time
ever you have two polls came out last
month you have the american federation
of teachers which is one of the biggest
teachers unions in the in the us a
leftist organization
plus the democrats for education reform
also had a poll last month both of them
finding republicans up by one to three
percentage points on the issue of
education so it's a seismic shift in
support we have the misery index coming
out showing that democrats are doomed
and i just want to tell everybody
whether it's true or not you got to get
three of your friends out you got to go
vote especially right now especially if
you're in arizona if you're in arizona
and you don't go go and vote uh well
then you're making a mistake because
arizona's a big deal right now
and uh you know we had carrie lake on
the show i'm a big fan she's uh we
expect her to win but uh here's what i
gotta say you know they're projecting 30
to 40 seats lost in in in the house
now is the time when you can see your
enemy in retreat you get all your
friends you call everyone you know your
mom your brother your sister your
cousins your niece your nephew and say
guys come on we're all going to vote and
we're going out for pizza so now it's
time to do it so thanks for joining us
man we also got ian hi everybody back
from ohio i took a nice vacation for the
last couple days get some fresh air
cleaned my mind great to see you guys
again corey i mean the school choice
thing
you were a pioneer and this is like
before the nonsense of of people having
zoom calls with tc and these weird stuff
that teachers are telling it's really
i'm happy i mean all of the closures and
the teachers unions over playing their
hand have really supercharged the
movement for school choice 2021 was the
year of school choice we just talked
about arizona with kerry lake up in the
polls for today's election arizona just
passed the gold standard of educational
freedom every single family regardless
of income will be able to take their
kids education dollars to public private
charter that's apocalyptic for leftists
yeah because they don't have kids but
we'll get into all that stuff beautiful
evolution yeah and lydia is on vacation
so chris is here hey what's up everyone
handling all of the live production and
everything else so uh without further
ado let's jump into this first story the
apocalypse is nigh my friends politico
reports china vows to encircle taiwan
with military drills in response to
pelosi's visit tensions reach their most
precarious point in more than a quarter
century forget the politico let me show
you the visual
from 12 p.m august 4th to 12 p.m august
7th the chinese people's liberation army
will conduct important military
exercises and training activities
including live fire drills in the
following maritime areas and their
airspace
they're just announcing they're going to
surround taiwan and start firing
into the air while nancy pelosi is in
taiwan
i don't think anything's going to happen
well i'll put it this way this is
happening
i don't want to be
naive and optimistic or biased to assume
nothing could happen you know because we
often talk about the battle at fort
sumter fort sumter when no one thought a
civil war would break out so they're
like picnicking on the hillside are we
falling into that trap are we sitting
here being like ah they're not gonna do
anything to pelosi or
no we we have to fear corporate and
medical tyranny not war on country owned
country they do not want to pose
two great economies against each other
they can suck us dry of our interest
back to the federal reserve right now
we're not
we're not staring down real nuclear war
i don't think no we could be staring
down some stupid sanctions
which they're already doing right on
taiwan they're banning imports of fish
or whatever it is um i don't know if
it's from response to this but
i mean at the end of the day when you're
banning imports you're shooting yourself
in the foot uh by
reducing by reducing the amount of
resources that can get into your country
so ultimately chinese consumers will be
the ones who are hurt by these types of
sanctions i mean it's true but
you see those videos of all the chinese
citizens like outside the banks they're
unable to pull money out yeah i mean at
a certain point china says it's now or
never yeah is it and considering how
close taiwan is
to china and considering china considers
taiwan to be china
there's a line you know what i mean like
the ccp might just say you know what
that's the line our our economy is is
shot our people we can't people can't
withdraw money from their banks we're
already facing this threat of you know
trump and and the united states as an
economic force is is probably not going
to last
they might be thinking and this is why i
i don't want to you know exaggerate what
might happen but i just want i also
don't want to ignore the possibility
china could be looking at this like
we can wait two years donald trump gets
reelected trade war again economic
crisis on our end we start losing
manufacturing or they can say you know
what
show up our defenses now make the move
before they do
and that might work out
i hate to say it but it might work out
okay
it might work out just fine as long as
the united states doesn't go after them
with aggressive military action
ultimately what's going to happen
i mean i feel for the people in taiwan
absolutely i do
i do but
is taiwan a sovereign nation
i mean if you ask americans the answer
is yes do what are americans what's that
based on like what's their basis for
making that assessment that taiwan is a
sovereign nation
like the history of taiwan and china i
don't know what do you mean officially
the republic of china this is where the
old chinese government fled when mao
staged his insurrection right so
basically this occupying force the ccp
isn't the real government of china it's
the republic right but the united states
officially does not recognize taiwan as
its own country right and so
doing that would be a huge leap
huge leap and it would have a lot of
implications
yeah but i don't think i don't like
nancy pelosi all that much i think she's
a hypocrite on the when it comes to
education for example
but
i don't think her going over to taiwan
and meeting with people is
going to be considered a real act of
aggression for one because it's not but
i think we i think the chinese
government might be more concerned about
us funding taiwan and actually providing
subsidies to them which could
change the the dynamic of power in the
future
yeah i'm surprised so many people
exist in this political mindset that
like china is a bunch of imbecile
children like do you think russia is
sitting there going like oh those
ukrainians keep eating fighter jets
somehow or do you think they're saying
we're at war with america right oh they
totally do it's trying to sit in there
being like we know the us doesn't think
taiwan is a country or do you think
they're saying the us is funding taiwan
so they can rebel against us and if it
wasn't for us involvement we would have
taiwan now
i think it's probably somewhere in
between
i think that that i think it's explicit
well the united states is definitely
being an economic opportunist in this
and i think that we're really our
government is pushing it as far as they
can go
but if china actually stepped in and put
troops on taiwan and started a situation
like like we're seeing in russia and
ukraine
i don't know if the united states is
going to send troops over i agree i i
think
we've got uh you know the strike group
carriers warships that are heading into
the region which is why china's
announcing this because they're
basically saying back off
i obviously the u.s is the only reason
china hasn't just invaded taiwan i mean
maybe the fact that taiwan does have its
own defense but of course we're we're
supporting them in many ways we we
we utilize taiwan for tons of business
if it weren't for us they would not have
as much economic development and they
wouldn't have the resources to defend
themselves it looks like at the same
time we uh benefit china with with trade
as well so they might not want to have
an act of aggression against taiwan
because they don't want to lose
economic trade not if they're already
hurting not if not if trump's already
started a trade war with them not if
their banks are already in dire straits
not at the sentiment of the american
people is that in couple two to four
six years we're going to strip all the
manufacturing away from trying to stop
doing these deals with chinese-made
products if they're planning ahead
i gotta say it looks to me like the next
four years is going to be made in
america donald trump he's running again
he's he's
i i they have to pull joe biden out that
right there is red flag sirens for for
the democrat chances of winning what are
they going to do aoc
actually we have the we have the article
we're going to talk about yeah
and and i
there's no way aoc beats trump
knock on wood because i maybe something
happens but if trump wins he's going to
say
he's exactly what he said you remember
when he had that quote michael moore
brought it up he went to the auto
manufacturers and said if you make your
cars overseas i will charge you a 30
tariff to bring them in and no one will
buy them yep and then what do we see in
michigan they reopen plants they brought
the cars back from the plants from
mexico and then as soon as trump's out
alls and they shut it down they're
moving things back out again china knows
this they know it better than we do i
can only imagine that they're like
looking at their watch saying we hope
trump doesn't win
according to wikipedia taiwan is part of
the republic of china which is a country
and taiwan there's 168 islands in the
republic of china taiwan makes up like
99.98
of the land mass
so it is its own country the republic
okay so
the last poll uh that was released out
of the hill has trump up against biden
by what eight points it's like not even
close um
biden's done i mean did you see that
there was a video that came out that
everyone thought was a deep fake
because his eyes are like lasered and
he's like you guys
it's like
i'm sorry i don't i don't think it's a
deep thing i think they just gave him
uppers well is he going to get better or
worse between now and 2024. that's a
real question it's like they're they're
they're giving these pills and it's like
squeezing blood from a turnip you know
like there's nothing left to get out of
this this man they're probably pumping
him full of things to fortify his blood
this poor man
they're they're he's getting how much
you want to bet he gets like iv
treatments oh no for real oh i i used to
get them yeah you can get all kinds of
nice vitamin cocktails and we can put a
lot more in it than that we get nad
because joe rogan you know he told me
he's like you gotta do the nad and then
i was like i'm not gonna do as much as
he does we'll do it sometimes yeah you
guys think gavin newsom has any shot at
the democratic primary yes absolutely i
just don't think they can win yeah but
look you know you know we can't i can't
see everything you know i've made some
good political predictions i've made
some some big bad ones and you know for
the most part it's like here's what i
think might happen
and that's why i try to just say you
know what man
all that matters is it's primary day
right now
midterms are really really close three
months away
forget who you think is going to win
just get all your friends every single
one you know what you should do tell
your friends you're going to go vote
call them all up every single one post
hey we're meeting here this time we're
all going to go vote and um like if you
live in the right in the same district
or whatever and if they if they're
grumbling or whatever just say hey we're
going to go out for pizza
on the way we're stopping to vote then
we're going to get pizza there you go
that's what you do i think eric's going
to win that race
i do too yeah wonderful i mean trump
endorsed him
in missouri you saw that yeah he's
probably got something good going for
him if what if trump
you may or may not have endorsed him you
were mentioning like trump trump
endorsed someone else with the wrong
last name in first name right yeah
wasn't that did he laugh was that jd
vance's race like he endorsed one of the
first names and then the last name of
the other guy and everybody's like
really just trolling us on all and all
these assistants this is this is what i
love about donald trump you know it's
like
his foreign policy was some of the best
i've seen um and i i can talk all about
getting our troops out of the middle
east north korea i bring it up all the
time because these things i think are
important i i absolutely despise i did a
segment today talking about china
talking about pelosi
uh middle east you know with a drone
strike
on that taliban leader and all this
stuff and i just absolutely despise
the american war machine a bureaucratic
state military industrial complex and
intelligence industrial complex
if they if they came
and were honest with legitimate purposes
for what the us were to do overseas i'd
be like wow this is serious stuff it's
just lying everything is just not true
and it's exemplified by
nothing they ever say aligns with what
the supposed interests are you know like
uh here's an example what really pisses
me off is joe biden's quid pro quo with
ukraine when he says you're if you don't
fire the prosecutor you're not going to
billion dollar loan guarantee then he
says
i did this because the prosecutor was
corrupt and then we got someone in who
was good the funny thing is the
prosecutor was investigating the founder
of barisma as soon as biden gets him
fired the founder came back to ukraine
and then as soon as trump came in the
founder fled sounds a whole lot like
biden was covering for barisma because
his son worked there so don't give me
this bs they're spitting in our faces
now they talk about the need for taiwan
and and the south china sea i'm like you
are just liars the gulf of tonkin
that that happened in what was the 70s
the the false flag to get involved 60s
false flag you're right late 60s to get
us involved in vietnam i was not alive
i grew up hearing the story about how we
were attacked and then i think it was in
the 2000s they finally admitted like oh
yeah we kind of staged that thing so we
could force america so that we could
draft people so you know what i'm done
with it donald trump can come in and he
can say we're bringing all the troops
out i'll be like good you deserve it
because the united states is not
justified i know china's got africa and
south uh south american oil
exploration and development and the belt
and road initiative these things are a
big threat we're going to have a
multi-polar world where there's
potential for real-world conflict but
the united states the the deep state
bureaucratic state military industrial
complex has done nothing to unify
americans to justify any of these
incursions so you know what i want
donald trump to come in fire everybody
start fresh that sounds good to me i'm
with you i used to be very
anti-imperialist in general just like
down with the military industrial
complex and then now recently i'm like
replace it with what
there's gonna be a military complex on
earth whether it's the american one or
the chinese one or whatever yeah but it
could be national defense as opposed to
national office yeah well but that's
what they think that's what they say
right like the reason we we are in
afghanistan is because they're like well
we leave it's a power vacuum you'll get
terroristic ridiculous you'll get china
and i'm like hey yeah i hear all that
but you lied to us to bring us there
okay so you know no that's not how i
apply you need to give us a legitimate
justification and was the afghanistan
war a huge success did we change oh yeah
why did we just leave it was a success
for halliburton no i mean yeah what else
made money off of it they they i it's
just
look i've been following some of this
stuff
i'm not gonna pretend to know more than
those who have access to confidential
information i don't so my position is
only yo all i know is you're wrong and
you're lying and whenever we say please
justify what you're doing they give us
bs
barack obama killed a 16 year old
american citizen abdulrahman al-awlaki
and they said oops
i'm like that's it sorry you're done my
my my uh consent has been rescinded for
what you what you were doing i'm a
little kid i'm like i don't know all
about this stuff i get older i'm like
hey i got questions about this then
obama's like we're gonna come in and
pull our troops out and then he gets in
he goes i'm gonna blow up those kids too
many right i'm just like dude no none of
this trips out drone strikes in
yeah you know look donald trump pulled
our troops out of the middle east and we
got more drone strikes i can understand
what trump was doing in that capacity
bringing our troops out means you're
you're pulling out this the american
power structure which displaced the
existing power structure and caused a
huge problem created isis
and now as we're pulling back we need to
basically prevent
an expansion of say isis
i don't blame trump for the fact that
other presidents started wars i don't
blame barack obama for the fact that
george w bush started wars i blame
barack obama for drone striking children
for drone striking military-aged males
and then putting more troops in the
middle east i blame the administrative
state for lying to us about why our
troops are over there and i and i credit
donald trump for trying to get us out
not that he did everything perfectly far
from it but no new wars pulling our
troops out i thought it was a good thing
i want to see trump going and fire every
one of these people nancy pelosi i'm
sick of it get these incumbents out i'm
just so i'm fed up with this stuff i
wish that they were honest but like if
they were to be like we're in
afghanistan because we want to harvest
the hair with the poppy for the opiates
so that we can make fentanyl and and
then get enrich our pharmaceutical
companies if they were like i mean i
think that's what we're doing over there
amongst the oil extraction i mean ending
the drug war here would probably help to
ease that pain
how would you do that how would you do
that by decriminalizing the production
and manufacture and distribution and
consumption
of opioid products including
heroin which is a wildly unpopular idea
but it's
it would open the market up to
to being able to actually verify if
something was laced with fentanyl if it
was safe it would make treatment much
more normalized it did this you could
tax it
oh yeah i knew it
you're like no none of that i mean it
could happen but
you know and from a libertarian
perspective that makes my skin crawl but
i'm much more grossed out by the thought
of us
killing citizens in other countries
and you know and calling it collateral
damage that's an awful thing i look at
fast and furious with obama giving the
cartels weapons these these people are
not your friends they do not have the
best interests of america at heart you
look at what happened with michigan with
the whitmer plot and then you see in the
trial it's like oh they were almost all
informants orchestrating the thing from
the get-go and the guys i think the
jury world two of them were entrapped
like these people are not your friends
but you know what else i realized from
all this nobody's in charge
i was i was i was thinking about it i'm
like you know we talk about how there is
uh in china
you can't you can't have a show like
this criticizing your own government in
china and then i was like why do we i
mean they certainly don't like me they
want to get us banned they don't have as
much power here like what i mean is the
political elites the uniparty
the bureaucratic state no single group
has enough power to destroy another
group and so there's a constant you know
battle for power right they're people of
principle who are like we should have
decentralized power they get exploited
by liars cheaters and thieves
it's better than china though you know
so i'll take it but there's no guarantee
it's going to stay that way even though
we have a constitution
you have
people on judges that they'll just
interpret it a certain way and they'll
say well i know it says this but
um i don't think constitutions limit
governments in the long term they limit
them but they but it's not a guaranteed
limitation did you see in pennsylvania
they the supreme court just ruled that
mail-in voting is allowed and i'm like
the constitution explicitly explicitly
says in the pennsylvania constitution
that absentee balloting has to follow
these rules and they went yeah but
universal mailing is a different word
amazing
i mean we have a lot of activist judge
judges in the education realm for
example west virginia just passed a
very expansive school choice program in
2021 they're getting families signed up
over 3000 families were already signed
up for the program
and a judge that was
previously endorsed by the teachers
unions previously funded by the teachers
unions
um a circuit judge ruled to stop the
program for whatever argument they
wanted to make west virginia west
virginia they had a
the biggest victory of school choice in
2021 now the judges are jamming it up
and they're saying and they do this
every the teachers unions fund people to
to try to block uh i am using any any
mechanism they can i am a huge fan of
the free state project yeah and you know
we've talked about this a while ago i
don't want to take away from that a lot
of people are talking about moving in
new hampshire to join that and that
that's a good thing
but i got to tell you man i am getting
more and more interested in affecting
massive political change as it pertains
to west virginia in the direction of
freedom and liberty and libertarianism
because we had our senator shelly moore
uh capito vote for gun control
in west virginia supporting no no no no
no so the one thing i don't want to do
and why i've been somewhat reluctant to
be
you know too active
is move here two years ago and then all
of a sudden be like time to throw money
at local politics and like you know i
don't i don't i don't i don't like the
idea that someone would do that
especially because we have a successful
company
but
one thing that did happen was i had
locals who were uh concerned about
critical race theory in schools and they
asked if i would contribute to them you
know putting up a billboard and i was
like whatever you know it was super
cheap to put up a billboard saying like
no crt or something and i'm like that's
what i say anyway and now i'm thinking
like
maybe maybe
considering this is the second most
trump supporting state
i don't think people would be upset if i
came in and said we're going to support
values you know freedom liberty
individualism and all of this stuff and
maybe just start
doing what we can politically maybe with
just messaging with local ads
you know i don't know i don't know if i
want to be involved in overt politics
but i'll definitely be involved in
messaging spreading the word
school choice is a must absolutely gun
rights absolutely that's what you
already do
so it's just an extension really of what
you're already doing and honestly it's a
defensive maneuver
because you're doing it in reaction to
policies that have been passed that are
you know basically it's like they're
spitting in your face
i mean the other side's doing it too so
if we don't play the political the
critical process then then we lose west
virginia is awesome and you know it's
it's i have this there's this quote of
me i think the mises caucus actually
made it cause i said it on the show i
said you know back during the ron paul
revolution days i was like i don't agree
with a lot of his world view when he
talks about like you know his religious
perspective or things like that
but i prefer him over everyone else
because he was like i'm gonna leave you
alone and i was like hey i dig it okay
i'll be over here doing my thing with my
friends and you go over there and then
we got no beef i'll comment i'll share
you know we'll do trade when we do trade
but we'll do our thing yes he made a
bunch of really great points he was like
if you want socialism in america just
make a socialist comm you know what's
stopping you yep why are you trying to
go and take everyone else's stuff and
i'm like he's right
you know like me and my friends we had
our little hippie houses where we all
like lived in a shoebox apartment
sharing rent so that we could work less
you're free to do so
i i dig it i i like that idea so i like
coming to west virginia and then what i
see is
people walk around with guns people get
along
it's just there are some issues it's
funny like weed's super illegal but like
in maryland it's not but then maryland
guns are super super illegal and i'm
like listen
i want to be able to what's what's the
shirt
i want to buy uh
i want to buy weed from my gay married
neighbor with bitcoin while you know
carrying my weapon to protect protect
myself in the process
you know can we just
like you're not hurting anybody the
action of should be stopped we shouldn't
be doing this pre-crime stuff yeah and i
think um
this socialist doomsday scenario could
turn out in the future if we don't free
kids from the government school system
and i think you know hey i've been here
in two years but a lot has changed over
the last two years and i think part part
of that is because when the government
school teachers unions closed the
schools for so long even lobbied the cdc
to do so
families started to see that the schools
that they thought their kids were in
that they otherwise thought were doing a
good job based on the state ratings or
whether they were getting good grades on
the report card started to see that
there was another dimension of school
quality that they hadn't really thought
about as much which is whether the
school is teaching in a way that aligns
with your family's values so you
mentioned crt earlier there's gender
ideology in the classroom now as well
and just left versus right bias in the
classroom as well that could
that's
really
increased the momentum for
school choice as well let me pull up
this tweet from you actually
so uh corey a deangelis on twitter says
the gop is a golden opportunity to
become the parent's party and you linked
to this uh this data showing that
republicans are now favored on the issue
of education for basically the first
time ever
is it really ever
yeah well according to this chart it's
going back two decades at least and i
don't recall a time of democrats ever
being
down on the issue of education this is a
seismic shift it's like a double digit
swing in the other direction
this is apocalyptic for the left yep
because as we often mentioned and i i'm
not i don't mean to be crass
they're substantially more likely
to abort their their children
they're substantially more likely to
give drugs to their children which will
prevent the ability to reproduce
they're substantially more likely just
in general not to have families
so the saying goes leftists don't have
kids they have yours they need to be
able to convert the children of
moderates and conservatives otherwise
their ideology ceases to exist and this
is why terry mcauliffe in virginia had
to say i don't think parents should be
telling schools what they should teach
it's a deeply ingrained belief that the
kids belong to the government schools
this idea that it takes a village well
it turns out it's a deeply unpopular
belief especially after the school
system treated families so bad after the
past couple of years and i think the
opponent the republican glenn younkin
tapped into something which could be a
blueprint for success for the gop and
libertarians as well
going forward because how are you going
to defend that
this idea that parents shouldn't have a
say in their kids education yeah it's
insane for any ideology too it doesn't
just because it happens to be um on the
backs of people that were like talking
to kids about sexuality it doesn't
matter you want to talk to kids about
religion and tell them not to tell their
parents it's still messed up you still
don't do that stuff we have entrusted
the public schools they violated trust
in my opinion can you like real quick
give an exam like explain what school
choice exactly is yeah the money that
would have followed you to the
government-run school on average in the
u.s according to 2019 data from the
census bureau was about 16 000
per kid wow if you wanna take it to the
government school you can if you like
your public school you can keep your
public school but for real but if not
about half of the funding or so
depending on the law that you pass will
follow the child usually to something
called an education savings account
which the parents could use for private
school tuition for a charter school for
home-based learning options like a micro
school for example it's the idea that
the money follows the child it's time to
start calling this universal school
access yeah we advocate for universal
school access for all children you
oppose access to schooling for children
you monster with
i just call it funding students not
systems it puts the other side on
defense because if you want to fight
against me you have to argue why we
should fund the system and not the
student so it's sure i'm going to call
it universal school access i'm in favor
of both universal school access for for
all families usa
listen listen a impoverished family
should have the right to get access to
the school for their kids that they
think is right for them don't you i mean
you don't think we should segregate
schools do you no and i think that well
there we go kids in incredibly violent
dangerous inner city school systems
should be able to go to school somewhere
else if
if the funding is there
honestly you know from a libertarian
perspective i say just get rid of as
much public education as possible but if
if it's going to be a fight to do that
let's take every step possible and at
least let these poor kids have a choice
it's it's brutal public school is a
brutal violent place for a lot of
children oh yeah yep i certainly know
that it's terrible yeah you were
homeschooled right
briefly so before kindergarten my mom
homeschooled me my brother my sister uh
i think
as the story goes we were homeschooled
the moment we were alive yeah like she
was always you know trying to show us
things
and then i think i learned how to play
chess when i was like three not that i
was good at it i'm not saying that but
like i was being explained and taught
the moves of a chess board and stuff
like that
and then when uh
me and my siblings we were going to
school we already knew our basic math
before even kindergarten
we started with catholic school which
was private my family chose it because i
thought it was a better school and then
hard times
after fifth grade we moved to a public
school and wow i think this is one of
the greatest experiences of my life to
be honest going from this this private
catholic school which was very strict
but not particularly harsh just it was
like very rigid like if you didn't have
your tie you got a misconduct slip you
need to go home and get it signed and it
was like oh no you don't have your
little sailor tie and then you go to
this public school where
nobody did anything and like you didn't
have your homework who cares what are
you gonna do about it the kids were
doing drugs and then for me to be thrust
into that i think was actually a really
good thing because i had discipline from
a private school private catholic school
then i got to experience the real world
very very quickly and so i was like okay
i don't want to do those things i see
why they're bad
but i also see real life so there was a
net benefit to having experience from a
more disciplined place
and then realizing just how bad public
schools were
i mean i i gotta tell you like going
from a private school which you know
they have their problems too it's like
it's perfect and then going to a public
schools like i was not even in school it
was like
daycare basically yeah
yeah which a lot of parents didn't get
uh starting in march of 2020 and then
you had some
uh people in the school system saying
i'm doing my job i'm educating through
zoom but it's like well if
but one of the side benefits of the
school system is that you have in-person
child care services
and
taxpayers want to have agreed to pay 15
16 000 per year i would say they don't
agree in the current situation either
but they certainly wouldn't have agreed
to raise taxes as much as they have if
the only benefit you were getting was
something that could be um
done via khan academy for free how about
zoom detention remember that yeah log in
to zoom and stare at a blank screen and
have the cops come to your house if
there was a nerf gun behind you on the
wall that happened too i had saturday
detention once i was i was high school
very briefly and i came over what
happened i think i cut
class or something because it was just
so awful and then they did this thing
where they changed our schedule so we're
you know i'm in eighth grade and it's
like 7 30 in the morning until 2 30 is
school and then when we start high
school the local high school says we're
doing 10 45 a.m to 5 30 p.m which was
like a huge shock to all of the freshmen
coming in so i was just like this is
ridiculous and i left so i come back and
they're like saturday detention for you
and then i was like what happens if i
don't come and set a detention like you
get another one and i was like okay and
what happens if i don't go to that and
they're like you get another one and i
was like i don't think you're
understanding
what this means and i'm like okay and
then i just didn't go like nothing
happened
it's nonsense even then now zoom
detention is funny it's like turn your
tablet on and then sit in your room i
guess you're like playing video games i
mean and at the same time you had the
the teachers union board members
vacationing in puerto rico saying
there's no way i can go to work in
person but i can be sitting here on the
beach uh tweeting out uh photos on
instagram well if it was safe enough to
travel on vacation why wasn't it safe
enough to go back to work either full of
it man
and you know it doesn't even matter i i
don't want to have a political argument
over schools
with like like teachers in the unions
i'm like my attitude is strictly you
know hey good for them if you like your
teachers and you like what's going on
that's really really great for you i
think we need universal school access
for kids and you know that way
you know not every teacher is good and
so the parents need to decide
you know what the proper schooling is
and they shouldn't be barred from that
so if you have a kid who's in an um let
me ask you this
is it unreasonable
if you have a kid who lives in a poor
area the parents should be allowed to
have that kid go to a wealthier
neighborhood school right yep that's
universal universal school access
that's that's what we're fighting for
for the underprivileged inner city kids
to go to where the rich white kids get
to go right and if you look at the uh
the percentage of people from different
backgrounds who are using these existing
programs it tends to be lower income
families charter schools you look at
national center for education statistics
data more likely to have a higher
proportion of non-white students and
more likely to have a higher proportion
of low-income students you look at the
dc voucher program for example where i
live and the average household income of
students using that program i think is
about twenty eight thousand dollars per
household in dc
uh ninety five percent of the students
using the program in dc are black or
hispanic yet you had the biden
administration coming out against uh the
program uh with funding following the
job what's their argument against
universal school access you're stealing
money from the public schools to which i
respond
the money doesn't belong to the
government schools education funding is
meant for educating the child not for
propping up and protecting a particular
institution why should poor children be
barred from going to the fancier wealthy
private schools we should guarantee
universal school access so the families
can can
you know get a voucher and go to the
wealthy private school or the public
school in the better area universal
school well it's funny is the left
supports a whole bunch of initiatives
that allow public money taxpayer funding
to follow the decision of the family for
or student for higher education we have
the pell grant for low-income kids with
a gi bill for veterans you can take the
money to a public private religious or
non-religious university it doesn't have
to go to one particular place based on
your address we do the same thing with
head start and pre-k programs the the
families can choose
religious or non-religious private
providers of pre-k
and that's the funding following the
student we do the same thing with food
stamps for grocery stores you can take
the money to walmart trader joe's
safeway you don't have to take the money
to a residentially assigned
government-run grocery store what
happens if everybody signs on to this
and then all the kids from the
surrounding area want to go to this one
school that's really good it overloads
their their capacity they expand yeah
that's a good problem to have currently
if everybody wants to go to that school
today
they may want to do it in their minds
but they can't do it because they don't
have the financial means to do so when
they're already paying through the tax
system for the government schools dc
public schools spend over 30 000
per student per year but like year one
so everyone decides to go to this big
good school and only like 10 of them can
get in because they have 10 times the
amount what happens is it like do they
have to draw straw first come first or
do they raise the price because supply
and demand well new schools pop up
people submit applications to open
charter schools all the time and and
schools typically will will expand so if
in one year too many students are trying
to enroll they'll say we better capacity
so we've you know through a random
lottery these are the ones that ought to
come we're sorry but we will be
expanding next year so you can next year
but in the moment and let's say you
can't go to the best school you can go
to the second best school it's better
than having no choices at all let's
let's jump to this uh this next story
from the new york post
misery index shows democrats face
mid-term rout as voters rage at biden i
think the issue of schools is going to
have is obviously having a huge impact
on this not just the misery index but
basically for those that aren't familiar
the misery index is looking at inflation
unemployment gas prices and it is so bad
look at this misery index this the
unemployment spike plus the inflation
spike
it is just bad news across the board for
regular people
this typically indicates there's gonna
be a major party switch like the
congress is gonna flip people are just
saying we're done with this
i think on top of this you have what we
saw in virginia with yunkan parents have
become a voting bloc which is hilarious
and the democrats keep attacking them
the end result is going to be
well
i think it's hopeful based on all of the
data we've seen democrats are going to
get purged from congress and the senate
joe biden still in the presidency so
it's not like there's going to be a lot
of movement
and then if the republicans can make
their argument properly 2024 comes
around you get a republican president
and then all of this stuff gets gets
shoved through donald trump one of the
big reasons that i said it was august
2020 i was going to be voting for him
was because school choice
was was was on a second term agenda
and what i was saying to people is
you've got pushback on the critical race
theory in government contracting we
can't have that
but school choice makes the most sense
there's no argument against it it should
be a left-wing position
when you when when i you know so i'm
previously mentioning calling school
choice universal school access because
the idea is
families can choose where to send their
their kids they will get a confirmed
right now a poor family can't go
to a private school but with the school
choice program basically they can now
that's that's but you know that's not
what they want right want you in these
propaganda indoctrination centers where
they can control what they what you
learn as a student and they can just
crush the joy out of learning absolutely
the crazy thing though is school choice
is a it should be a left-wing position
yeah i mean if you if you pull the
constituents on the ground pulling
consistently shows super majority
support for example the latest real
clear opinion research pulling from 2022
finding that 72 percent of americans
support school choice funding the
following the child to public and
private schools that work best for your
kid but there was also super majority
support among republicans democrats and
independents it only comes to the
elected officials in the state houses
where you see republicans being much
more likely to vote to support school
choice than democrats and that's all
because of the political power dynamics
of the teachers unions we were speaking
a little bit earlier that randy
weingarten's union who had this poll
backfire on them showing republicans up
on education but the american federation
of teachers the second largest teachers
union in the u.s
in 2022 99.997
of their campaign contributions have
gone to democrats so the democrats are
in a catch-22 situation right now and
this is why this is such a good
opportunity a golden opportunity for the
gop to become become the parents party
because if they talk about education the
democrats are going to have to respond
in one way or the other if they come out
against parental rights like we saw with
terry mcauliffe well that's a disaster
with the new special interest group
which is parents but if they come out
for parental rights well then randy
weingarten the unions are going to get
mad
ian do you mind talking about what
you're mentioning before the show with
your family yeah which which one exactly
you're watching the show
you're talking about yeah 100 yeah so uh
before the show ian was mentioning that
um
his you were talking to your parents
about biden's brain yeah yeah the last
time i went to ohio about a month ago we
were talking about biden and i was like
it goes it changes some time time but i
was like you know he's losing his mind
and my mom's like i mean he's no he's
not that bad you know or he's no he's
fine and uh and i was just like
in shock but i left i didn't you know
i'm not getting emotional about this
stuff so i went back a couple days ago
and she was like i was like you know the
problem with biden is he's losing his
mind she's like yeah he is and the media
is talking about it now and that's
probably why she started acknowledging
it yes as soon as you see jimmy kimmel
talk about it and everyone laughs then
it's okay to acknowledge it this is this
was a really great example i was like i
was i was saying ian i was like tell
them that we on this show have been
showing examples of this for for years
the the true none of shop at a pressure
and so
they need to look it's not about
watching this show it's about watching
shows in this area where maybe it's
because we're younger and more attuned
to what's going on
we we see these things we know what's
happening but when they sit and they
watch corporate press they're they're
not realizing it they're way far behind
everyone else the reason i bring this up
is this is why democrats retain power
because regular people aren't
you know i shouldn't say regular people
but the older generation is not getting
real information they are getting fake
news from the corporate propagandists i
mean weren't they saying that people who
were questioning uh biden's cognitive
abilities were making fun of like a
stuttering issue that he had it wasn't
that that was one of their first defense
tactics
i've never seen someone with a
stuttering problem put a metal on
someone's neck backwards and walk off
stage the wrong direction that's not
stuttering well to be fair it is a
common symptom of stuttering when you
reach out to shake invisible hands
when you say words that aren't real
everybody knows when you have a stutter
you don't just stut stutter you also
make words up like like batacaf care and
next now wrestling and trinidad a shop
of pressure you actually only put your
son on on boards of oil companies
getting too close to small children the
doctor's like oh yeah we talked about
that a lot too it's the way he handles
kids on stage the way that he smells
he's not actually sniffing the hair it's
just and women's just so disturbed
another simple sarah reed i brought up
tara reed we talked about that for a
while i mean the buying tar read
allegation against biden is damning i'm
just imagining there's like a little boy
and he's stuttering and the doctor is
like we couldn't help but you have all
of the symptoms of a stutter
you're repeating the first syllable of
the word over and over again and your
son has been placed on the energy on the
board of an energy company in ukraine
i've been doing that since i was nine
man oh no
most common symptom you know i'm going
to push back on on school choice a
little bit because i'm wrong i'm
absolutely wrong because i love it but i
need to know i need to steal man this
thing let's go so
what happens when
a bunch of people likes keep one decide
to keep the money they're like okay i'm
gonna homeschool my kid the mom decides
i'm gonna keep the eight grand a year
but then she just doesn't teach the kid
and that's already happening in the
government schools you want to get rid
of all government schools because some
of them don't teach anything yeah i mean
this is using an outline but but let's
let's more directly respond to this i'll
make one point real quick
when i went to school i had teachers who
didn't teach us anything and it was it
was punishment it was a prison so it's
ungovernable do you think it's
ungovernable no we have uh just like a
health savings account where you can
only use the funding for health services
it's an educational ebt card for
education so you can't go and buy you
know
big screen tvs if you do you'll be in
trouble for fraud even even if you did i
think that'd be a better use of the
funds than throwing them to an endless
money pit into the government
guidance counselors i got to tell you
i think many kids would be better off
not in these schools yeah and not being
educated at all because some of these
schools are doing worse than nothing oh
yeah so the other question is how do you
what do you do in a situation where the
the surrounding schools all send their
kids to the middle this one really good
school and then they all lose money and
start to go out of business or have to
fire teachers and you've got these like
derelict schools that are having i mean
that's the argument that let me i just
want to jump in like imagine there was a
bakery that sold turd rolls
and nobody wanted them but the
government was forcing by taking your
tax money and then funding the turd roll
bakery and then one day someone comes
along and says people should get a
choice on what they eat for breakfast
and they shouldn't have to send their
kids to the turd roll bakery
if the turd roll bakery collapses and
all the bakers get fired i'm sorry dude
people just don't eat crap yeah so the
problem is it's not a good argument to
trap the kids in there like the thing
about a business is that they can fail
when they do bad
the bad thing about business is that
they can become exploitative when they
grow large and cumbersome like you know
starbucks for instance when they start
shoving out or i shouldn't single them
out any major fast food can shove out
local mom and pop shops there's a
problem when they grow too large
but
we can address the problem of monopolies
we also need to address the problem of
unf you know uh unfallible government
institution perceivably like well the
school if it's not doing well give it
more money it's like no no no no and you
got to recognize that there is no
utopian school solution
because human beings are imperfect
fallible creatures so we can't make any
system perfect but we can remove
government monopolies
and government incentives for corruption
and coercive school policies what do you
think about curriculum
one more on that point um
the reality is school choice is a rising
tide that lifts all boats competition
leads to
improvements in every sector of society
including in k-12 education and there
are 28 studies that exist on the topic
25 of the 28 studies find statistically
significant positive effects of private
school choice competition on the
outcomes in the public schools so they
up their game in response to competition
like you see everywhere else and at the
end of the day if
the people who make this argument this
is going to destroy the public schools
they don't have much confidence in the
public schools that's not a good
argument to trap kids in there it's a
good argument to let them leave yeah
destroy away please yeah like let the
bad businesses fail are they considered
businesses schools i mean they are with
higher education they are with pre-k why
is it why isn't any different for k-12
education we have a market for schools
already the private sector already
exists in k-12 it's not just that when
when people are looking to buy houses
they check the school districts
specifically because they're shopping
around for good school districts
and you you will find areas with bad
schools people that well we shouldn't
move there because they're schools that
kind of thing already exists the issue
is my view of school choice is like
you've got a poor family living in this
area and the school kind of sucks they
can't afford to move they can't afford
to jump to a wealthy area but they can
say we can take this this universal
school access and send our kid to a
better school and give them a better
life and you can save taxpayer money at
the same time they spend fifteen sixteen
thousand dollars in the government
schools you can structure the program to
be ten thousand dollars per kid or
twelve thousand dollars per kid so you
can have a taxpayer savings you could
even give some of that money back to the
public schools they end up with higher
per-pupil funding um and you can create
a win-win situation oh interesting so
you could give a small percentage to
schools where there are no kids going
just to keep that's a really good idea
see there we go i want to i want to jump
to this next story because the most
important story of our generation the
hill opinion aoc is the democrats best
shot against trump in 2024 um ladies and
gentlemen i agree go wise i completely
agree um i i agree 100 percent
there is no one that i think in the
democratic party that has any kind of
gravitas or media poll i don't think any
of them can win gavin newsom looks like
american psycho aoc can't win either but
best shot agreed trump couldn't win
either remember that in 20th it's true i
i would love to see aoc when i just i
think she's going to be more likely to
engage with libertarians and third party
candidates too really i think she is
i think she can't help herself she can't
stand the people that are bought off
i don't know i don't i don't know she
might be moving in that direction but
but we'll see we'll see i don't know
that for sure i mean i think this would
be a gift to the gop and the libertarian
party uh they they remember what they
said about trump the piedmont yeah right
yep they were like no one will vote for
this guy i think aoc is their best shot
i still don't think she can win she will
just turn 35 before the election
but considering here here's the here's
the deal folks
the economy is in the gutter the misery
index is through the roof
none of this is gonna is gonna is gonna
make it work for the democrats now by
2024
okay maybe the republicans win in
november and then they just
royally screw things up then aoc comes
in and she's like i'm gonna do all this
wonderful free stuff and then maybe she
wins because you got to consider this
it's a couple years from now
you've got new young people and entering
the voting pool and you've got older
people aging out so every every election
you see a shift that that that
that changes the older folks are way
more conservative than the younger folks
gen z is a little bit more conservative
in some areas but they're nowhere near
as conservative so in two years you lose
a decent amount of boomers and you gain
a slightly larger amount of progressives
how about a desantis versus aoc matchup
yeah just you know cool conversation
i would love to see aoc win because it
would be as funny as trump winning i
wouldn't be a fan of what you would try
to do to be completely honest but it's
like but hey gridlock you'd have uh
republicans holding congress yeah if we
had total gridlock it would be
wild i'm just you know when trump won
the first time i had my feet up and i
was just laughing my ass off yeah so
i bought an extra bottle of port in
2016. i was drinking pork at the time
that was my thing and um
when he won florida i was like it's
going to be a long night
i didn't look at the news at all when i
was at work on election day i just
didn't want to know i was too depressed
about hillary clinton winning and i got
home and turned on the news and i was
just laughing hysterically that it was
that this was actually reality
i got i felt like someone a ghost
punched me in the gut i woke up at like
3 a.m and checked i was like what the
[ __ ] is going on
yeah i remember my my australian
friend's social media post that's the
only thing i remember from from the day
that results were announced it just said
lol america and that was exactly how i
felt
someone someone superchat jealous do not
speak of satan else the devil might
appear free aoc
and my attitude is kind of like look man
i feel like if aoc were to get in it
would just be better than what we
currently have with the uniparty
establishment like biden and i don't
think it would be good but i would laugh
when aoc won
against crowley i laughed i was like
good good riddance to these these
establishments she'll you know i don't
care
aoc has proven in my opinion to be
duplicitous deceptive deceitful
fabricating stories on january 6 and all
of that stuff
i still would rather see her
than any one of these establishment deep
state whatever uniparty trash shells
she's a pretty good actor right i think
it would just be hilarious
handcuffs on for a while she lies just
like all the rest of them so it's not it
doesn't make her worse unfortunately
they all of them lie well i'm just
saying it would be clown world times 10.
yes wouldn't it come on it would be
funny to have president ocasio-cortez i
embrace clown world
i do not reject clown world i embrace it
it's like look if you can't get trump to
come in and try and clean things up you
can get aoc to burn it down i guess
let's burn it
[Laughter]
if that's what people want i think it'd
be funny a righteous fire a righteous
healing fire righteous but but this is
what they do on the left
they they literally riot no we don't
want any of that stuff you know donald
trump coming in you know i want him to
fire everybody oh yeah please don't burn
it literally let's just let's just um
destroy it ideologically and make it
into a joke i'm imagining aoc she's
sitting at like the situation room and
the cia comes in they're like mr madam
president we have these uh
kill lists the disposition matrix these
are the people who got to assassinate
and she's just like
no and they're like you have to and
she's just like i don't know i don't
know i don't think i wanna what is this
and then it's just like
how do you how do you work how will look
when when they go to obama here's what i
imagine
cia goes to obama and says sir
we have these these wanted men here's
what they've done we have a chance to
take them out this is in line with
foreign policy it must be done and he
goes okay
launch the drones
aoc is going to be like what
huh
no
i don't know and they're not going to be
able to do any of this stuff i think
it'll be like fire all those guys that
wouldn't listen to you i want to see
instagram live streams of shopping
that's what i want to see from the white
house how how do you here here's my
here's the point i'm trying to get to
with donald trump they accuse him of
working with russia it is a ridiculous
thing what are they going to accuse
aussie at doing
she's like she's a look i'm not trying
to be a dick but she's an airhead
you know what i'm you know
she's just
she's not going to do what they say yeah
what would her scandal be i don't know
what would her scandal be
aoc's scandal they try to use to
ruin her or it could just be that she
just says probably partying probably
partying do you think yeah and that's
not that's not very bad or something
that's not there's a lot worse scandals
there's people with with kill list
conspiracy theories attached to them you
know they said reagan wouldn't be
president right they're like a movie
star president then you get donald trump
a reality tv real estate mogul i think
asu could win i really do i just don't
think it's likely if she wins it makes
it so much more likely libertarians have
a shot you'll get a comedian in the
white house
why do you think so well you get you're
talking about voting for a clown why are
we not having a cool medium
so what's what's happening with the
libertarian party uh do we know do you
have any updates on
who's running
so we don't have any official
announcements but i think in
you just said dave smith you said
comedian right so we don't have any we
don't have official announcements but
the top contenders right now are going
to be dave smith
justin amash and and spike cohen
although he keeps insisting he's not
running he's there's a lot of energy and
support behind him so those are the
those are the three people who i see
falling into that role and there has
been a little bit of a little bit of
whisper and buzz about maj toure maybe
jumping into a vp really yeah that'd be
cool
education secretary so i can get into
the department absolutely thank you
education secretary scott horton will be
you know in charge of
yeah foreign policy that would be
awesome
like build a mini ramp in the in the uh
um
situation room i want to see i want to
see maj toure uh running
running senate and congress you see this
is why he teaches conflict resolution
classes he had one over the weekend so
that you know maybe
press secretary malice absolutely that's
just what that's that's all i want
i'm ready he will do it he's going to be
the greatest one bitcoin one bitcoin so
we got the times square billboards up
and we we've included him on them
because you know we're just we're big
fans and i thought it would be great and
then he was he said to me he's like well
at least if we lose we had more fun and
i was like yep
yes i think we're gonna do it we want to
see malice as a press secretary we gotta
we gotta start hooking that man up with
one bitcoin per month one bitcoin per
month i mean that's not that much for a
press secretary we're talking we're
talking like what is that going to come
out to like
270 a year it's a high salary for for
government position like the cap is 174
though per year oh it's it's capped out
you can't think no but in a campaign you
can pay more can't you oh and a campaign
yeah yeah yeah campaign so we'll we'll
have to figure something out worth it
yeah absolutely
i'm putting together an excellent roster
for you all i like how it's like we're
sitting here it's kind of like you know
bsing and then corey's like i'll be i'll
be education secretary and you're like
sure
i've got a list it's a good list you're
on the list five years later you are and
we're like man we're just talking smack
the department of ed's gone the next day
i'm firing myself oh yeah
i saw a bar tab from before they signed
the declaration of independence the
founding fathers and it was like
yeah it was like 160 bottles of liquor
for 60 of them you know some insane
number where they all drink like two and
a half bottles that's amazing they're
all drunk and they're just like screw it
we're independent and they're like yeah
and then they wake up in the morning
like what did i sign
i'll put i'll put reid coverdale in
charge of uh transportation yeah he's a
trucker so
i'll read i know him through twitter but
i've never met him face to face
yeah you know spike cohen is brilliant
he is he's a great articulate messenger
i really he's very humble too i didn't i
had no idea how brilliant like he's a
genuinely nice person
and and i love libertarians but
we're not all nice i don't consider
myself a genuinely nice person i can be
kind of mean i've never seen spike cohen
be mean never so so look there's a new
libertarian party obviously right now oh
yeah you guys took over yeah the old
libertarian party got really crazy
remember when um
um uh
well i'm sorry who was running for
president i forgot her name
joe joe joe jorgensen joe jorgensen when
she when she did that marxist
authoritarian statement on twitter oh my
goodness i was like this is the funniest
thing i've ever heard from she said it's
not enough to be not racist we must be
actively anti-racist super sweet lady a
super sweet lady
did not have good uh people on her team
but like it was funny i i thought it was
hilarious the libertarians were telling
us what we must do i know i know
it was very painful that was very
painful what we must
what was the the party's stance on like
the the closures and the lockdowns at
the time so the party did not make a
single statement
not on their website not email not
social media not twitter nothing for an
entire year come on this is your
opportunity this is the time to do this
this is your time to shine ball whiffed
baldwin so we have come out a very
strong opposition under new leadership
to lockdowns uh all manner of mandates
vaccine mandates war
what i don't understand how the liberty
look it sounds to me like the
libertarian party was taken over before
you guys it was it was taken over in
2006 by
the the insider term is prags
pragmatists but you could consider them
as more centrist moderate types
so you could think of it as yangang
without the marketing but they're not
libertarian correct like like i i people
refer to me as lib center libertarian
centrist or whatever and i'm more in
agreement with you guys than that oh
very much so no they're they they
started out kind of like modern uh man
so the history of this is really brutal
and i had to go through recently about
15 years of staff reports to understand
everything that happened so exciting
well really more i went back to 1996. it
will bore you to death but i personally
found it fascinating to watch the party
get taken over by neocons at one point
and and watch membership and fundraising
an in interest tank and then get taken
over by woke top woke types and watch it
tank again the reality is libertarians
at large the movement don't want
anything to do with that but these
weirdos got into positions of power
and really soiled the branding and name
and it's just they were more organized
at the time and who knows i i speculate
there why are you libertarian at all
well you're mad at your dad you know so
you don't want to vote the same party as
your dad's you'd pick us instead it's
like your weird boring centrist
rebellion wow yeah but now we've we've
taken it over we've taken it back we've
taken it back
was it because of the covid stuff or was
it already in the world we were working
on this uh
we kicked it off at the
summer of 2017. so i was already active
in the party and then was kind of
confused when i saw people coming out
against ron paul in the party i was like
what what total embarrassment i'm so i'm
ashamed this was like the pragues or
whatever yeah
shameful shame i don't understand how
are they against ron paul i don't know
mean words that he had friends they
didn't like someone said something mean
that's not pragmatic at all no it's not
it's not pragmatic it's bizarre weird
culty gatekeeping like you don't have
any friends who've ever said anything
mean that you didn't like in your whole
life
it's an unreasonable
human position because if you if if
you're libertarian in any respect ron
paul being like i'm going to leave you
alone you're like okay amazing perfect
the man has done so much to advance
liberty and
in spite of these weirdos who had
control of the party for a few years ron
paul even in the republican party grew
the libertarian party tenfold because a
lot of times people would get
politically engaged they would go where
ron paul was at and they would say uh
the rest of the party is nothing like
you and then they come and they join us
i'm glad he had kids because i like rand
paul too yeah i do too i do too so we're
onward and i do say rand paul is a
libertarian but i'm saying
i'd say he's pretty close i think he's
not totally sure if he's a libertarian
or republican and that's probably his
his internal fight and
one day he'll sort it out but i think he
is by far the most libertarian senator
we have
what's the difference between a
libertarian republican like in rand
paul's case
so
it's going to be a little bit of foreign
policy stuff a little bit of budgetary
stuff
and
his a
you know endorsing trump really hard
also came with the baggage of endorsing
a lot of his policies and although i
think donald trump was leaps and bounds
better than joe biden like he was not
libertarian he did not audit the fed in
his first hundred days like he said he
would he did deploy drone strikes to
syria he did engage in
economic foreign policy that i didn't
like even though i loved that he didn't
start new wars you know he was he was
cracking down with tariffs and and
making things kind of kind of messy for
us
in that respect so those were things he
did that were not libertarian of course
the the border wall people flipped out
and lost their minds on and the
libertarian party
the membership is kind of split on
borders which
other people don't want to admit i i
think that the truth is the best thing
that you should embrace and the reality
is there are people in the party who do
not want total open borders yeah it's
not controversial to want ellis island
style immigration by the way that is not
that is not a crazy
um closed borders position there's
i i don't think people understand that
there's
you need borders a country is defined as
a nation with set boundaries borders and
i know that i've had these interesting
conversations because i'm fairly
libertarian with other libertarians who
are like you believe an imaginary line
is going to keep me out and then i'm
just like no i think we limit our
jurisdiction right like we say we won't
send our armed dudes defending us beyond
that line yeah and then if you cross
that you're now agreeing you're entering
the territory where we have jurisdiction
over what we think is appropriate for
our society i'm not an anarchist
um
i believe there's got to be some laws
there's got to be some you can have an
anarchy with laws too you can privately
provide laws you can and this is sort of
the nuance that most people just their
eyes glaze over when you dig into it so
but i'll i'll try
ideally right in your in your perfect
world or your near perfect world since
there's no utopia we have private
borders where everybody owns everything
everything is privatized you decide who
comes across your borders now the
reality is that's not the world we live
in and we have to deal with tragedy of
the commons and we have to deal with our
tax dollars and so
from a libertarian perspective i would
want as many people who are peaceful to
be able to come here as possible but i
also wouldn't want to guarantee them to
write to vote yeah because those two
things
those are totally separate and it's
unfortunate they don't get separated in
the immigration discussion there isn't
something interesting that's happening
with the way democrats are handling
immigration is we're developing a
service guaranteed citizenship style
governance i don't think it's a
completely bad you know starship trooper
style but i don't like the idea of them
just opening up the border letting
everybody come and then creating a surf
class
yeah i don't like surf class i don't
like tying migration to voting rights
and citizenship
if we got rid of birthright citizenship
that would be wild if we got rid of like
in our visa program that you can bring
over your whole family that would also
be well these are some interesting
things we could consider
to make immigration lessons we we need
to reconsider this what people need to
understand about voting we have to hear
from the left they say it used to be
that you could only only land rich white
landowners were allowed to vote and then
it was like well you understand why that
was for one
yeah racism for sure no problem like it
it's it's not the same as people view it
today it was like there's different
times but the reason why landowning was
a component was because there were no
ids
if you lived here you voted here if you
didn't live here you didn't vote here
and so that's why it was the landowners
were voting eventually we were like hey
you know people are renting a lot yeah
we should probably allow them to vote
because they live here it's like oh okay
if we are now getting into a new
territory of
you know
the way we're handling immigration and
everything then we might want to update
how we handle uh citizenship yeah so we
had birthright citizenship specifically
because of the end of slavery
it wasn't intended to be that someone
could you know in china they do uh
pregnancy tourism birthing tourism right
that a pregnant woman will come to the
u.s to give birth so their child will
have dual citizenship and then they'll
go back i have friends who who were born
here because of that exact thing now i'm
very sympathetic because their parents
were terrified of communist china and
were trying to ensure that their
children would be able to grow up here
and that they would have a place to flee
they were they were basically you know
political refugees
which is which is a thing that i'm
sensitive to but but that also doesn't
necessarily mean that you need
citizenship
wasn't didn't milton frame make the
argument that uh open borders would be
fine and dandy if we didn't have a
welfare state yes if there wasn't yes
there's a lot of issues i mean and we do
if we got rid of that that would be a
huge thing we can't have open borders
and uh non-citizen census at the same
time right so
that's what's happening with california
they're trying to let as many people in
as possible because it gives them extra
congressional seats and more electoral
college votes and california does have
welfare programs for people who are not
citizens they absolutely do state level
welfare
doesn't this argument apply to the state
level too though like people can move
from
from arizona to california to get more
benefits so here's my biggest argument
for closed borders it's not people from
mexico or canada coming in it's people
from california like me moving to texas
now i'm like you texas it like someone
needs to build a wall
inner country of closed borders texas
states
i think
i think that that might happen you know
so we've i was talking about uh
abortion being a catalyst for civil war
yeah and one of the scenarios that we
talked about was what happens if in
texas where it's now banned
a man and a woman you know hook up
they're together at eight months they
split no man says there's no way i can
have a baby without without him so i'm
going to go to colorado the man says
i won't let you do it you're going to
kill my son and then she flees
the question is then how does texas
handle this conflict with colorado when
the feds are like we're not being
involved they've got a law on the books
right now that basically
rewards snitching
yeah
it's it's intense and this is the part
where you know like personally like i'm
pretty pro-life i am five months
pregnant right now could never consider
getting an abortion i get a little
freaked out when the government starts
incentivizing you to spy on your
neighbor and turn them in for crimes
yeah oh yeah
that's rough there was this company i
remember like 15 years ago that was
telling people to go out of their house
go outside their house and write down
all the license plates and they would
pay them yeah and then i was just like i
saw people posting on facebook about it
and then i was like spying your
neighbors for cash wow and they're like
uh well i mean because they didn't
realize what they were doing they're
dumb people we had it in california
in in this in the city of l.a during
lockdowns there were hotlines and tip
numbers to report businesses
that were divided so what i did was i
very carefully took little screenshots
of the california website and all their
official announcements and i got my own
number and superimposed it and plastered
it all over the city so you could call
559 i'm a nazi
and i didn't type that out i typed out
the numbers but it is 559 i'm a nazi and
it was a fake tip line wow and you would
get trolled as you recorded your
neighbors
then they have people snitching on each
other because you could only like work
out one time a day in some places
australia yeah i was uh so i was
thinking about the scenario and then one
thing i was thinking of is like it's
probably easier to put it as
what happens if in texas there's a
federal military base yes and there's
you know a woman and a man and they have
a kid and then eight months she's either
she's you know a service woman or
something and so she goes in for this
procedure and they approve it
what is texas going to do
file a lawsuit and it's going to get
argued at the same time i don't know if
they're going to file a lawsuit
well the state of texas i mean
absolutely will didn't they file what
you're saying is the state will look the
man in the eye and say your son will die
and then we'll take it to the courts
yes i can't imagine the man's gonna be
like i'm gonna let my kid die well we'll
probably see him on the news in some
tragic incident but that is how
government operates yeah is it's a
slow-moving creature well
sort of if by design if a woman
kidnapped a a a if the child is born at
eight months yes no man rushes him into
a military base they're going to bring
her out and give the son back and said
we can't do that but if it's in in her
womb they can say it's viable we we
could deliver it but we're going to kill
it and that's why we have like
man it's terrible but the reality is
that people do not agree
and i think some of them are being
disingenuous but they do not agree about
women when human life begins and that's
what got us into this whole argument i i
know i like
abortion such a topic that when it comes
up we go crazy but i just have to say
life begins at conception there you go
it is there's no there's there's anyone
who's arguing otherwise is lying to you
period
that it that's when life begins now you
can argue human consciousness you can
argue insolent you can argue all those
things happen at different points i
don't care but a unique set of dna is in
cellular reproduction independent
that's that's life
and the goal post will move in this
argument i think throughout eternity
which is why i am so in favor
of people just peacefully separating in
this country as much as they can
as much as they can if that just means
strong federalism and aggressive states
rights i'll take that
worse we saw what happened you know when
we had some states that believed in
denying personhood in some states that
didn't
and you got people like john brown so i
feel like if if we go here's what i see
happening if we go the national divorce
route we peacefully say
you guys do your thing or we go even
strong federalism let's say let's let's
take federalism yeah let's say that's
not always going to be that way right
you'll get a supreme court that's
hostile to states rights and then
they'll change they'll just keep
changing back and forth well but here
here let's outside of that let's say
because of the the speed at which
communication technology yeah it's
different now than it was back then
let's say we get strong federalism we we
end up with republicans winning in
november we end up with donald trump
winning in 2024 and then people just
keep these people are like trump fires
everybody all of a sudden the
administrative state the federal level
is crippled the federal government loses
tons of power
texas says colorado we don't care what
you do
then what happens when you get one of
these scenarios
where a guy's son is taken
because the woman is pregnant and she
says i'm not going to deliver this for
you because we're fighting and we don't
like each other anymore
this guy goes to texas without a strong
federal government to intervene
texas either says yes we'll help save
your son or we won't they might say look
we're not going to go and take a woman
like it's never going to happen so he
says i'm forming a posse what does
colorado do when a band of armed dudes
go in to rescue their child
what would happen
if a woman kidnapped a two-year-old the
two-year-old
child
jumped state lines and and law
enforcement across the board said we
will not get you your son back even
though we know it's a crime we know your
son's in danger and she is expressed she
will kill him i think that you're likely
to have a violent standoff which is
terrible
but we are already encountering
situations like that i mean what
happened with amm and bundy
right like
it's just they killed that guy you saw
that video it was terrible they should
the in the car so this is when um for
those aren't familiar they were
occupying first it's the land dispute
then it was there occupying a blm
building and there's a video of these of
this group driving in a car and then you
see the window shatter they were fired
at dude jumps out and then i i could be
wrong it's been a long time but he
reaches into his into his chest holds or
something and then they just unload on
him this is a uh bureau of land
management building you said yeah yeah
yeah bureau of land managed not to be
confused and it was there it was it was
like the second incident with the
bunnies i think and this guy
they argued well he reached for weapons
so we know we shot him and then people
pointed out you shot at him first and he
was reaching in self-defense this is why
we need police choice we talked about
this yeah two years ago
i'm not as i'm not privatize the police
i'm not as libertarian as y'all when it
comes to all of that stuff i mean you
agree with school choice right the
reason that schools do such a shitty job
is because they have geographic
monopolies you can make these same
argument for police departments
you can't hold them accountable from the
bottom up if they either discriminate
and kill innocent people or if they just
don't come in time it's but it's but it
is different it's you know law
enforcement we have people with guns
going around shooting people we need
strict accountability we need a set of
ground rules that apply to everybody
constitutional rights
so what i like is duly elected law
enforcement sheriffs sheriffs i don't
like appointed police in big cities that
are super crooked i would go either way
i would go duly elected law enforcement
or privatized police where their
contract do they're not
continued in perpetuity that is very
important i think police should be held
to a higher standard yes they should we
got to end qualified immunity that's
really critical
and
and we need to make it much easier to go
after their bail or their their bond or
their insurance because you can do that
but it's so difficult and complicated
and obnoxious
possible i really just think it comes
down to we have a cultural problem we do
absolutely if you know i i look at these
old tropes of officer friendly you know
he's walking down everyone's waving a
free hot dog for you officer and the cop
was concerned that if he screwed up the
whole community is going to get mad at
him so he's got to be this this good guy
yeah these days it's like you're in a
city and the cops like don't know you
don't care tell to a judge yep i'm not
i'm not sticking my neck out for you you
get a you get a cop who uh accidentally
commits a crime and then they they cover
for him in in new york i personally
witnessed a
false arrest of a photographer of a
photographer i i was lucky enough to
have filmed it and then the false
charges were dropped and the cops lied
under oath and got away with it i've
seen him shoot at and harass homeless
people and skid row now
i know that a lot of homeless people in
skid row have psychological issues they
can be a danger to others and themselves
but i've spent years down there doing
volunteer work and
completely unarmed and i've been able to
de-escalate situations with violent
people
so i'm a i'm a small woman and so i
didn't have the need to shoot anyone
i would like to think that law
enforcement with proper training can at
least be as good as i am cultural decay
in cities you know
as far as i've experienced living in the
suburbs and in rural areas no issue with
sheriff's department sheriff's
department deputies always
calm reasonable it's probably because of
density yeah in new york though you know
i lived on the block where a black
nationalist executed two cops minding
their own business sitting in a car but
you what people need to understand too
is that guy he didn't live there he
showed up to this neighborhood just to
kill these guys yeah he posted you take
two of ours we take two of you yours or
something like that as a reference to
michael brown
but on the street every night there are
floodlights on every corner and cops
like it's basically an occupation
they're the fifth largest standing army
in the world that's insane new york
police department so
you go outside when i was living in this
neighborhood at night there's two cops
on every street corner large flood
lights and it's like in a residential
neighborhood people there don't take
kindly living that way man no and so it
it breeds animosity and there's a lot of
people who do like it because it's
unsafe they feel like it's unsafe well
it's out of necessity it's not like they
chose it and said please put up
floodlights in my neighborhood yeah
with guns yeah and i lived across the
street from all this stuff but then you
had a guy who came i think he came from
like baltimore or something and he
walked up to the car and he just killed
these cops
so the issue i think is cities are too
dense the culture is too fractured this
idea of multiculturalism is just
it's a failed experiment yeah we've
outsourced our governance to dc it's
insane like you can't have 700 people or
a thousand people govern 350 million
it's not happening we're ungoverned
essentially and then they're passing
thousand page bills and stuff without
reading them
i think the other problem is a lot of
the over criminalization with victimless
crimes and
if you had more drug legalization for
example you wouldn't need as much uh
rights enforcement done
by gangs um because it would be things
that are legal on the books but you
wouldn't you would be able to enforce it
through
uh
the police instead of through gangs but
where would kamala harris get her slave
labor to put out wildfires
drug drug enforcement truancy i wonder
what you guys think about drug
enforcement because you were saying
earlier legalized drugs you mentioned
portugal that had in 2000 an experiment
where they legalized maybe not every
drug but a lot of drugs nationally um
i'm not sure exactly how that turned out
but like
drugs are getting more potent more
addictive pharmaceutical companies are
building them like are you also saying
that pharmaceutical companies should be
able to at least sell heroin to kids
those are already legal well think let's
think about how that would work like in
reality you go into cvs or drug stores
most is even baby formulas locked up
so i don't anticipate that there are
going to be a lot of places that would
actually sell
hard drugs like heroin to children i
couldn't even get
diet pills when i was like 18. i
remember having a friend who really
wanted to get diet pills when she was
18. it was like illegal when the the
highly potent drugs are arguably because
of them being illegal so it's easier to
transport large amounts when they're
they're super
also true and when cannabis so cannabis
you know i i was suffering horribly from
crohn's disease and was able to use
cannabis to alleviate pain and also some
of the horrible gi tract symptoms i had
the alternative
is opioids and things like tramadol
that's the only one that's actually safe
for people with gi pain but that's still
an opioid that's addictive it's a horse
what about uh like elimination diet like
michaela peterson oh that's what i did i
had i had to go hardcore very strict
carnivore diet
they worked yes it did within about 72
hours so by the way
by the way the doctor was going to take
out my colon
i'm in my 30s they were going to put a
bag in me give it a year
give it a year and if it wasn't fixed
take the colon out
insane
i'm a woman within like of child bearing
age and they were going to take out my
organs
and i hung up the phone and after
pumping me full of many pharmaceutical
drugs i tried all the things i'd hugged
a purple crystal at everything in
between i don't care i'll try it
uh and i was like the only choice i have
left is to try a radical change to my
diet because i've tried the first you
know 20 hits on google and
was it the gluten
no i'd been on a gluten-free very
healthy vegan diet
for
15 years exactly
so when i say healthy vegan i mean i
wasn't just i wasn't eating like vegan
powdered doughnuts like well what was
causing it you know
stress inflammation i had toxic mold in
my house and it was a number of factors
that built up to the point where i could
not tolerate any food i was down to
eating five things sweet potatoes
avocados
dates something else i could
occasionally eat a beyond burger but not
an impossible burger that was really it
uh mustard
and
so i changed my diet i had to get very
high to be able to eat meat because it
was so disgusting to me and within about
72 hours my horrible
gastrointestinal internal bleeding
and violent spasming had changed i would
have spasms that were so bad it was
partial paralysis for me every morning
every morning so you start eating meat i
started eating nothing but meat wow
and i didn't have any other food
cravings for three months
and then i was nothing but meat nothing
salad salt
not meat salt and water that is it
wow that is where'd you get your
vitamins from
meat salt and water the meat has the all
the vitamins you need it's got what
plants crave it just apparently so and
within 72 hours the worst of it was gone
and within a year
i was almost back to normal well it's
like they say meat is magic did you get
rid of the black mold that when you're
environment i moved oh move out of the
house yeah i hear that's insane black
mold toxicity just i have other friends
who are who are on healthy vegan diets
i'm not talking about the
weird uh soylent green that's come out
into the into markets lately but they
totally thrive but they didn't have the
stress levels that i did combined with
the toxic mold and the other weirdness
going on so wow
yeah life-changing i i was eating a lot
of grains
last year
and uh like my weight was going up and
down in like uh 2018 i started losing
weight and then i started eating
bread and garbage and not really caring
about it and started gaining more weight
and then in november i just
stopped eating sugar yeah so now so i've
ranchers a little bit it was like i
totally cut it out yeah like all the way
down maybe it was like 10 carbs per day
just like as carbs as an aside like what
i might be getting from some vegetables
and now i'm doing like you know 25 to 40
carbs per day nice but uh my health is
greatly improved my energy is way up it
was bad i used to finish my morning
segment then i would eat dinner and then
just fall asleep and then wake up an
hour before this show and like groggily
just yeah and then i was just like well
it's because you get tired when you eat
and then i stopped eating this the
grains that's what you eat and now i
just feel like i've got electricity
surging through me 24 7. that you do so
since becoming
since becoming pregnant by the way and
this is another
a good thing to know like when you're
pregnant you have kind of free-floating
stem cells in your body i have been able
to eat a lot more i can eat fruit i had
a couple there's only one brand but a
couple of gluten-free cookies
earlier today didn't kill me not
bleeding out of every orifice of my body
you know obviously i'd look like an
ebola victim earlier you wouldn't want
me in here it's terrifying it seems to
be working now
so you speak in my language about diet
healing the body yeah what so then when
we talk about legalizing drugs i'm
concerned i just watched this dope sick
movie i was talking to you guys about
earlier about the sackler family and um
purdue pharma sending basically telling
everyone that oxycontin is not addictive
that was their official statement from
the fda approved it and they sold all
this all these people killed millions
like hundreds of thousands of people got
addicted and got into heroin because
they couldn't get their oxy so
what if we legalize drugs then not only
would pharmaceutical companies be able
to pump
stuff like potent oxytoc oxycontin into
12 year olds but like so could people on
the street i would imagine and it would
just be like i mean they already do
they'll regulate it it's so easy to get
it they could still regulate it so
there's all different varying degrees of
regulation that it could or could not go
through
but i got to tell you man it is they're
pumping kids full of ritalin in schools
like if you're moving too much you have
you get in trouble if you don't put your
kid on ritalin in public schools
so i think that problem is already there
i do think it would be easier for us to
expose it
if a lot more things were deregulated
and this would also when i say direct
legalize or deregulate or decriminalize
drugs we're talking about you could have
cannabis instead of opioids yeah it's
much safer
much much safer also for children there
are so many remarkable stories about
little kids taking uh rick simpson oil
and thc concentrates for major seizure
disorders where they're these poor kids
i knew i knew a guy who whose kid has uh
had epilepsy yeah and so he had him on a
keto diet and uh and medicinal marijuana
yep yep
several heal the
some of the i'm pretty symptoms i don't
know for sure my understanding is
i think it's reduction it helped but i
don't know what to to what to do to what
degree i know that he was like always
concerned and always calling it's a
reduction i mean these kids when i say
they have seizures i don't mean they
have a seizure a couple times a day they
would be having seizures on the minute
every minute it's it's
it's almost like you're barely alive
you're you're surviving you know you've
got a pulse but i don't know if i'd call
it living
and so to go from that to having a
seizure a few times a day is like a huge
improvement why do you think that
marijuana is still scheduled one
narcotic federally
because opioids competition competition
yeah i'm pretty sure they don't want to
lose that yeah
yeah it seems like uh like marijuana is
like and hemp in general is just tons of
different use cases it's incredible it's
just incredible yeah you can take it you
can take it like i do when you go to
sleep and you don't even feel getting
high i don't really like to get high it
is recreationally legal across in many
different states and i think we're
getting really really close to 30 34
states maybe where it's well not in west
virginia though yeah 34 states i believe
it's
uh medically legal and recreational yeah
west virginia's medically i have i have
faith they have a good libertarian party
maryland is decriminalized
but there's no like recreational
legality or anything like that it's just
like i think if you have it they don't
care or something but after a certain
amount they do i'm not entirely sure
west virginia it's like strictly illegal
you're thinking that the pharmaceutical
industry is focused on treatment it's
like a treatment industry it's not a
heal it's not a they're not looking for
cures they're looking for develop new
treatments experimentally like
i i i
okay i got more to say on it but i'm
absolutely sickened that that we would
allow this this beast to to thrive i had
another point that i'm going to make but
um i was told nothing i ate would affect
or change my diet
or my health
that's the craziest thing you know what
really annoys me is when people say
all that matters is calories and
calories out you know if you're trying
to lose weight calories and i'm like are
you joking
if you eat nothing but sugar but loca
you're you're not getting protein it's
medical tyranny i we talk a lot about
like government military tyranny um
about like corporate tyranny you know
what they call it i guess like but that
medical tyranny is a real thing and it
can really exist and i'm wondering are
we like in a system like that right now
well i mean i think that's what the fda
does food pyramid network because
so we can't get cannabis legalized even
though it's uh saving children from like
a life of hell with with seizure
disorders and keeping me from having my
colon ripped out of my body but we can
fast track all kinds of other strange
experimental drugs over the last couple
years but then we were
expected to not talk about say things
that weren't true about it like that was
all of a sudden like that's the
tyrannical part when people are like no
no no we're gonna follow the cdc
implicitly out in front and that's like
dude that's that's antithetical to our
system i would like when the republicans
win
to have an inquiry into the cdc
and
i want to see communications with the
world health organization i want to see
what they were approving why they were
approving it i want to hear dr fauci
testify as to everything that happened
and there's just look i'm not i'm not
going to get into anything beyond that i
don't know i just know that we need an
inquiry from congress we had under oath
statements we need to know when the
information was coming in and maybe
maybe there's a whole lot of
incompetence maybe there's a whole lot
of uncertainty and maybe there's malice
either way i'd like to hear it rand paul
is working on it yep he's great the most
libertarian republican there is is
working on it so i hope it's up to the
rest of them
to have the backbone i i i shout out to
a sheamus coughlin of freedom tunes
because we've we've done a couple uh
fouchy and rand paul
cartoons mocking the whole thing of you
know rand paul questioning yeah fouchy
about what's going on and stuff like
that so i really do appreciate rand
paul's work
and uh it's remarkable to me that
there's still people on twitter that are
advocating for full lockdown policies
and i'm like we're we're long since you
know over this one you still have some
places like in dc
in order to go to school ages 12 and up
you have to get a vaccine to go back to
school this coming fall still in 2022.
you know to enter the united states
people from outside the u.s have to get
vaccinated to come here
now my understanding is that the u.s
doesn't have a check system on it it's
the airlines that do and some airlines
correct
correct and they're not all electronic
verification yeah some of them are paper
but i i will also say there's absolutely
zero verification if you enter the
southern border illegally yes which is
what a lot of people are doing and we're
not checking for
actually i know a few people who did
that to get around getting vaccinated
just like walking across the border they
snuck in wow
well they were already us they were they
were already in the u.s they had to
leave and then in order to come back
with like visas and everything that's
just so wrong you know look the fact
that law-abiding citizens know there's
an open door they can't go through and
it's the people who break the law who
walk through it we got a serious problem
there the people who are respecting our
laws are the ones we want to come here
the people who don't respect our laws
are the ones we don't want coming here
like i think
like
every immigrant should be able to come
to the united states as long as they do
it legally exactly like trump said
legally it's just like gun control these
laws are not helping out law-abiding
citizens exactly
i think the the issue is you have people
walking through the desert they're going
to get sick they're going to die oh it's
a terrible it's a terrible thing to to
experience people people leave there's a
there's a group called border angels
that goes out and leaves water for
people in the desert who are
who are traveling they don't do
escorting
of immigrants as far as i know they just
try to leave water out and they'll
they'll go through and they'll find the
water jugs have had holes shot in them
i'm pretty sure it's illegal there were
a group of people they left food and
water on the desert they got arrested
and they were like we were just trying
to help people and then they said
something about causing problems for
wildlife pollution like you can't just
leave garbage in the middle of the
desert
things like that what do you guys think
about states like texas sending
immigrants over to dc well my first
response was that it's just helping them
that's what they want the democrats have
been shipping illegal immigrants across
the country so all they're doing is
helping them get this end of the country
yeah but many people commented saying
texas can't deport them so make the
problem
not texas and it's like okay well fair
point and then mural bowser panicked and
called in the national guard because
they're overwhelmed this is an
interesting juxtaposition with the
national divorce um argument
i feel like i'm not quite sure how but
somehow it's related texas has a problem
and they're like you know we're just
going to put we're just going to ship
our problem somewhere else yeah we're
not technically our own country but
we're just going to export our problems
over to you i'd imagine california would
load up all their homelessness buses and
send them to arizona if they need if
they if they didn't need the population
for their you know congressional seats
are the olympics coming
i don't know to l.a oh i don't know are
the olympics i believe the olympics are
coming to l.a wow there has been talk
of how they're going to deal with the
homelessness crisis in including putting
people on cruise ships yeah a lot 2028
summer olympics los angeles here's what
they can do they can get
blankets
that
look like rocks
oh man throw them on top problem solved
just nobody will see them you're out of
sight out of mind huh you got to see
skid row that would be a giant gravel
quarry it would be wild have you been
there lately yeah when was last
time i was like
three months ago how's it doing what's
it look like it's an open-air asylum
it's uh hypodermic needles and human
waste in the streets uh people
having mental breakdowns in the hospital
gowns
wow and it's and it's grown
it spread exponentially
so like i was there when it was just the
sixth street basically oh yeah no it's
much bigger than sixth street it's it's
crossed
it's crossed maine i think it's growing
and growing well how many block radius
is it would you consider the homeless oh
that's a really good question because i
don't know how far south it stretched so
it goes to that industrial area the
flower district over to 8th and 9th
street and now it's spilled past 8th and
9th up past maine
and then in the other direction i'm not
really sure it's
i mean it's
it's it's almost half of downtown l.a at
this point if you were to look at it
as a concentration of how many homeless
encampments there are it's it's half of
downtown l.a what's the libertarian
solution to the homeless crisis is it
privatize the roads and privatize the
sidewalks well we have to end the
tragedy of commons there's no perfect
solution but part of it is to end all of
the entitlement programs that people
flock to in downtown lake right at this
point it's just inhuman
and it's also dishonest because they
make all these promises and people camp
out desperately waiting there is
literally a nine year wait list in santa
monica for free housing wow and in
downtown l.a six years ago it was a two
and a half year wait now it's much
longer let's go to super chats if you
all haven't already would you kindly
smash that like button subscribe to this
channel and share the show take that url
post it wherever if you really do like
it head over to timcast.com
we're going to have a members only
uncensored show coming up at 11 p.m or
so it's gonna be a lot of fun we've got
more to talk about california and
illinois have declared a monkey pox
emergency and considering the
let's say adult nature of the
circumstances we're going to have that
one be uncensored for all of you but in
the meantime we'll read your super chats
all right
sam robinson says we don't bow down to
threats here here as much as i don't
like nancy pelosi china doesn't get to
decide when we have someone go and meet
with a with a delegation or or
government officials did she end up
flying there with fighter jet escort
that was their biggest she did that's
why she i think she had like four
well you know i think of it from our
perspective if if china was having
delegate meetings in like tijuana and
then they had a bunch of fighter jets
flying we'd be on high alert too i would
be concerned
and it's about commitment strategies i
mean if tim was coming into dc and i was
like and you're meeting with joe biden i
didn't like that and i was like well you
know what i'm going to get a bunch of
people to beat tim up you know what um
it wouldn't be in his best interest to
to just back down and say oh i'm gonna
back down everybody every time someone
tries to challenge me i mean no one has
addressed diplomacy yet could we try
better diplomacy yeah i want to video
chat with joe biden and xi jinping i
want to watch yes well i mean she was
like you play with fire you'll be burned
and biden was like oh
that's how i imagine it happened
he's quoted as saying that play with
fire you'll get burnt we're not trying
very hard
all right raymond g stanley jr says tim
dude have you been taking motivational
speaking classes that 4 p.m was
top-notch we do need more scott
presslers we do need to knock on doors
we need action i volunteer volunteer as
tribute at four i was basically saying
the primaries are today right so they're
going to the pro the the polls are going
to be closing soon yep if i don't care
what party you represent or whatever
you need to get three of your friends
go out and vote
you need to stop thinking about whether
you're going to win or lose and just
stand by what you what you believe in
and encourage as many people as possible
to be involved
because
what i was basically saying is 30 to 40
seat loss for democrats the democrats
better get out if they really believe it
and get every single person there to
vote and if you're a republican and
you're seeing that when the enemy is
retreating don't you say okay stop
everybody we're done no no you say rout
the enemy charge
like the patriot when mel gibson had the
flag and he's running in everything has
to be a reference to the patriot
based joe says
you can feel the excitement right and
then i think that's like 25 black flag
emojis
i like that they have black flag emojis
you know yes they do too it's very
anarchist yeah i just i was like i'm
wondering like
why do they have that do they do they
not have like black and yellow or black
and red yeah not yet not yet but why the
black flag that's really interesting
choice for them to make as an emoji you
know yeah
oh wow
waffle sense i says tim i i confirmed 16
friends for 16 votes all anti-critical
race theory all america first all based
now we just wait and see bro yeah let's
go
that's what i'm talking about you know
what general election day
we're gonna have like uh
we're going out for a big major pizza
party and then everyone's going to hop
on and then we're going to stop over the
local voting place and be like all right
everybody we're going to just real quick
vote i'm not going to tell you to vote
for i don't like playing those stupid
games where it's like ian did you vote
did you vote for my guy you should vote
so i just tell people to vote for who i
want them to vote for i'm real real
overt about it i don't i don't like it i
want people to vote if you if you vote
for not someone i don't agree with well
this is the way it works i mean i'll
make recommendations on who i wish you
would vote for but
but the questioning afterwards the
grilling who did you put
i'm not going to talk to you if you
didn't i don't you don't need to do that
you just need to say how do you feel
about the american flag
interesting and they could say i love it
be like okay you can come with me we're
going to vote
no i don't i wouldn't do that as a
prerequisite or anything i just think
whatever libertarian democrat republican
you better be telling everybody you know
to go and vote i'm not telling my
democrat friends that vote they need to
stay stay home and stay safe and save
lives
all right i mean considering the threats
but my thing is like i'm not going to
ask i'm just going to be like take your
friends and because the reality is look
i don't need to
most people they watch the show they're
not voting for critical race theory
they're not voting for authoritarianism
they're going to end up voting a
libertarian or republican or something
well and pay attention to the off-cycle
elections too i mean you have some of
these school board elections and these
other local elections on bonds for the
schools where the teachers unions
basically get all their people to show
up and it's a low turnout election so
special interests can take over which is
a another conversation altogether those
should be aligned with the general
strider says as a proud missourian i can
confirm i did indeed vote for eric
he was also endorsed by trump the one
yes the one the eric
man trump is i wonder if it's funny i
think when he trump my guess is that he
was like i i endorsed eric and he forgot
his last name she's just like whatever
and then later you've heard there were
multiple eric's like i'm just going to
what if what if it splits the eric vote
and then someone else wins no for real
yeah he says thanks for the advice trump
keep up the amazing work tim you got me
into politics i'm glad glad to see it um
i just want people to be involved you
know
all right let's grab some more what do
you have here
james alfred says tim you could be one
of the families picnicking at fort
sumter
do say it won't happen they thought the
same that's what i'm saying like maybe
it'll happen maybe you know you know the
scary thing about the pelosi thing is it
doesn't need to be a pla army soldier
like running up and going like uh nancy
pelosi it could be just a crazy
taiwanese guy yes it could be a friend's
ferdinand type situation could be a dumb
false flag too don't buy the
hype stay calm some some jet gets shot
down somewhere in earth don't snap to
firing a minute
a guy runs up and yells for the chinese
communist party in like north american
english and they're like well that's
what he said so
yeah you got to be careful about this
stuff
all right corey bolig says i've been
watching pop culture crisis it's a chill
show and you should check it out it is a
very chill show
if you guys are
overwhelmed by the absurdity and
insanity of
conflict and crisis and politics you can
go watch pop culture crisis and have a
laugh as money guns fire money into the
air and people talk about video games
movies and tv shows her bit on ezra was
his last name ezra miller miller it's
very funny mary's yes yeah entertaining
a pop culture crisis is a fantastic show
when uh we're going to be doing like
we're letting it get into the role like
the the flow of things you know
establishing their presence getting a
feel for like how they schedule and time
it out they've been being held hostage
because the super chat's coming so much
they just stick around for everybody
yeah and then after
probably in a couple months we're gonna
do a big marketing push we already got
brett and mary up on times square
billboards i saw the show i saw so the
laser eyes coming out of the laser eyes
i like mary restores my faith in gen z
i'm like maybe we're not maybe we're not
all doomed things turn around which is
on the show where like she's everyone
just she's a she's a represent
representative of all gen z this is how
they all are they're all good i want to
believe yeah yeah close your eyes
they're all they're all good
all right let's see
raymond g stanley jr says folks support
taiwan but not ukraine why chips
i think i don't know do the ukraine
people support taiwan too
well
did hunter biden go over there and have
a job and soak up a bunch of money and
there's differences i mean we were
working with ukraine on certain things
but it wasn't the same as taiwan correct
you know taiwan we've been working with
for some time now and even before the
chinese government fell i mean you know
i think that ukraine has regardless of
what's true
a an air a vibe of corruption that is
yucky and a lot of people don't like
that and no one is getting that vibe or
feeling from taiwan yet
ligament again says china faces imminent
economic and demographic collapse it
must move now if it is to quote become
economically developed before becoming
demographically old if they are to make
their go uh if they're to make their go
to be global
hegemon or even a superpower at all
during the century
they must act now yep that's what i'm
saying right
that's my concern is
kyle miller says the invasion of taiwan
would be our generation falkland war
economic issues in argentina made them
decide to invade the falklands to divert
attention from their issues
very interesting very interesting
assessment that was recent too that
falkland what was that the early 80s
when the british 70s
that was nuts that's really wild do you
hear about modern war like that
man
rick remorsen
lennissgate says world war one four
years civil war four years world war ii
six years for the fourth turning to be
done by 2028 it's gonna have to start
this year or next unless the cycles are
getting longer faster velocity longer
wavelength
you all know about the straw side
generational theory right yes
so there's four seasons there every 20
years
revolutionary war
80 years later civil war
80 years later world wars 1 and 2. yep
80 years later
something what do we got something
so the interesting thing is it goes
international conflict in the revolution
internal conflict and civil war
international conflict with the with the
world war 1 and 2. will it be internal
conflict i'm hoping that it shifts a
little bit and what we see is an
economic or infamous information war or
space conflict or short
whatever i'll take it as long as it's
not people killing each other in the
streets yeah let's find a different
conflict
aliens killing people in the streets and
humans fighting back can't they just
kill them in space yes okay do you
remember when the space force launched
yes and then we saw the uniforms and
they were like they were like jungle cam
or whatever yes the left started making
fun of them and posting images of like
what their suit should look like and it
was like their suit was like stars and
galaxy stuff and then everyone had to
point out to them the space force isn't
fighting wars in outer space and even if
they were they would be in spaceships
not floating around aimlessly in space
and even if they were they wouldn't want
to be invisible to their own allies like
the idea that you would wear space camo
is insane the whole thing is insane yeah
well i mean the space force itself makes
sense
you know it's like basically
we have space technology dedicated to
satellites and all those resources oh
there's stuff already up there
absolutely
yeah people don't understand is you know
the the the stargate program and the
warships that we already have and uh
we've we've traveled to multiple planets
and but humans will learn of that when
the aliens deem it ready i just think i
understand the criticism of camo maybe
why can't we go navy blue yeah
navy blue
when they're in the navy in water this
is brilliant netflix drops space force
official poster and official teaser
trailer it shows steve carell with like
it's looks like the moon his outfit and
then he's got the moon behind him so
he's camoed into the moon oh silly silly
yeah
all right
1776 is life says economic question for
all what is the better investment in the
next 10 years land or crypto
that's a tough tough choice to be honest
because i would say land or bitcoin i
would not say land or crypto that's i
was going to say what do you mean by
crypto because
bitcoin um
look if you bought bitcoin when it
peaked at 20k like a few years ago like
was it five years ago and then it
collapsed and they all made fun of you
you're still up if you just held on to
it you're you're up it's not 60k like it
was but it's still up and the dollar is
down right
land however
land is always good yeah so land is it
land is good land can be taken from you
i guess you know under extreme
circumstances especially if you're on
coinbase
your bitcoin can be taken from you but
uh it's a lot harder the thing of the
thing the cool thing about bitcoin
though is you memorize your wallet you
can flee the country and you still got
money in your pocket
matty g says tim today is the 58th
anniversary of the gulf of tonkin
incident august 2nd 1964. it is i
checked
yeah there we go
that's wild olivia angolia says tim
would you consider doing billboards in
frederick frederick maryland for the
education not indoctrination slate
uh sure i don't know anything about it
but okay i like that phrase that's
really good we go to we go to frederick
quite a bit um or i don't know if it's
pronounced frederick or frederick but uh
we're we're we're centralizing
everything we do in west virginia and
i'm much more concerned with west
virginia yeah because the best part was
when the cops in west virginia told me
that maryland is communist and i was
like i like these cups
yeah i like the billboard thing is cool
i need to i need to start having the
national libertarian party do that it's
cheap
like like in times square obviously it's
more expensive but it's actually cheaper
than people realize you know how much it
costs for one
display on a billboard like your ad will
appear one time in times square it's 20
bucks oh oh nice
but um you have to you have to you're
like you have to buy 10. well
i had such an ordeal trying to get
electronic billboards in la after 2018
they just would they rejected every
single thing i tried politics there's
rules about it so you can't do anything
political in times square for the most
part yeah oh and i tried making them
less political and just liberty embraced
freedom that kicked me off yeah we we
asked our agency if we could do a big a
billboard on one of the biggest that
said twitter is protecting pedophiles
and they said no unfortunately they said
sorry we don't allow ads that have
anything to do with pedophilia and i was
like i get it you know it is what it is
they were like
we'll let you put up a political message
or a message like that's cultural and
social issues but not that intertwined
so education not indoctrination
we could we could do a school choice
thing i mean my issue was that twitter
locked me on my account because i
legitimately called out real groomers i
wasn't talking about random gay people
right it was a photo of someone showing
explicit material to children and they
accused that person of being like you
know
of it being the entire lgbt community
i'll tell you one thing really funny
media matters is losing their minds
because i made a video saying obviously
not all lgbtq people are groomers right
the issue is that we have is that some
people are groomers and some of those
groomers happen to be lgbt
and
big tech is protecting them yeah so
they're trying to get me banned they're
like how dare he say this and i'm like
my video literally is me saying gay
people are not groomers you think
they'll cool off on the on the groomer
band going forward
they're creating a problem because they
are sort of using the lgbt community
to provide cover
for people who are predators and it's
just a wrong thing to do to gay people
too that's that's my point and i cited
the group gays against grooming yeah
which is
a real group a real group of and people
i'm friends with who are just like hey
you know we're not okay with this we
want we don't want kids to be around
some of these things and uh this is this
is politics man i think this is why the
gop is up on education even democrats
self-described democrats don't they
don't want the schools to to get into
the gender stuff it's deeply unpopular
position
and so you have people running to the
middle yeah
pims the great says i'm sitting in the
hole of an aircraft carrier looking at
one one tool that says made in taiwan
and another that says made in china
taiwan is its own country whether the
ccp likes it or not republic of china
interesting jack bailey says tim should
the people who perpetrated gulf of
tonkin be held responsible for the maile
massacre do you think the massacre would
have happened if the war in vietnam had
not had warned vietnam had not escalated
i am not uh knowledgeable on vietnam
to uh to a great degree to to weigh in
on that to be completely honest the male
eye massacre was like a bunch of
americans i don't know hundred couple
hundred of them went into a village yeah
it was just like they were at their
breaking point and the commander i think
was a captain started commanding them to
start killing kill everyone there's a
really good breakdown of it and the
psychological elements of it in a book
called um it's by m scott peck
the great the people of the lie it's
about evil it's a really good assessment
and i think based on that that it
probably would have happened anyway if
not there somewhere else
all right
uh i will say this too
people need to understand the challenge
that is uh that was a mosquito now
paranoid that uh the soviet union was
expanding there's real fears about a
unipolar soviet world i totally get it
but
you don't i just don't think you win by
being the evil that you're claiming
you're fighting i think vietnam was for
oil i still think that they were trying
to get malaysian oil off the coast maybe
but the soviet union was expanding
rapidly and there were real fears about
what a communist globe would look like
if the us got isolated out and and the
soviets ended up taking more and more
countries they would cut us off from all
of our supplies and strangle us out and
then you'd have a soviet authoritarian
slave planet i don't know it's it's it's
not so simple but i'm not a fan of the
intervention stuff and especially not a
fan of the false flags
all right jimmy kimber says uncle tim
big fan from australia love the show
even you ian keep doing you pierce can
you convince lauren southern to marry me
cheers mate i can't she is married she
is and she is not here
but uh
you know i'm sure he appreciates the
shadow thank you thank you sir who was
that by the way
that was jimmy jimmy kimber thanks james
james jimmy
paul
thungham says tim's get out the vote
message reminds me of a simpsons episode
where it's bart versus martin for class
president thinking he won bart is
thanking those who voted for him turns
out no one voted and it was too late
martin won two to zero i remember that
yes they were like oh i didn't vote he's
like what why and then martin got two
votes
i'm you know
people keep saying
ah the democrats are gonna lose and i'm
like sure sure sure but isn't that when
you charge yep no no when you when when
you see the enemy retreating you're
supposed to charge jar usually because
they might be enticing you into a trap
that's true yeah remember roe versus
wade
was was recently overturned and so
democrats are going to be very
aggressively organizing
to
yeah
deal with that
there's that famous story oh i think
it's a chuko liang was that his name
chris you know that
yeah i think that's
he knew he was going to lose this battle
so he opened the doors to his fort and
then sat on the wall playing a loot and
then when the enemy forces showed up
they stopped thinking it was a trap and
then retreated nice hannibal brilliant
old story the cart that cartesian
cartage and i'm not sure he pronounced
cartage uh but he he would do that
against the romans he was known for he
would retreat and then they would chase
him and then he'd come around and flank
them from behind
it's like devastating it's like in the
patriot
i love that movie it's a really good in
this situation like they're in a real
retreat because the school stuff has
been insane the last two years sorry
interrupted oh no just like when when
they're like you know cornwallis is like
is that militia farming at their center
and then they charge in but then the
other side of the hill they've got more
forces waiting for them they're like oh
no
that movie is so good it is really good
it's so good it's really long too
i just love the scene when he's doing
the prisoner exchange
someone made a meme about it when they
were like the years 2050 it's the second
civil war and prisoner exchange is
occurring and then they wrote a line
where it's like i don't know their names
but they're but their pronouns are
z-like and then you know the line from
the movie and a cheeky fellow who called
me a white supremacist bigot
yeah
cheeky fellow a cheeky fellow
all right what do we got here in the old
super chat box
juicy
juiced cyber new type says president
cortez china is threatening military
action again they must want to date me
that's that's that's it
that's our future president that's right
h music says every time someone pushes
on aoc for a bad decision
she'll cry in the oval office and it
will lead over into her press
conferences she'll be the crime chief
she'll be saying
she'll she'll be doing a press
conference and she'll be like yes um
peter from fox and he'll be like you
recently implemented a policy sign to
you know sign down to a policy an
executive order that does x y and z like
you just want to date me next from abc
same thing
i can't just want to date me you're
making this so appealing why is everyone
trying to date me here
murph tries diy says aoc as president
and alex stein as fox news white house
correspondent
end of the world season four
you know sometimes i feel like we
certainly must live in a constructed
universe there must be either we're in a
simulation or there was a god because
how can this be reality it's just it
defies probability and logic yeah things
follow patterns too readily for this to
be
improbable it's not random it's not yeah
no it's like
i don't know it's a simulation or a
construct someone was saying there's a
belief that you keep reliving this life
until you do it perfectly oh that sounds
awful and impossible like the best there
if you do it the best somehow like
there's a way to do this the best i feel
like i already failed but if you don't
have a nine but if you don't know maybe
i don't know if you don't remember then
do you run out of lives like mario i
don't know is there a cheat code
dmt
yeah yes so yes there is there's a hack
we got a big old super chat from charlie
red he says 15 years in business i am
losing my retail to amazon luck matters
check out my book the odyssey effect i
try to send you a copy hyper computer
and battle games also from kansas
mahaffel house ft
was it mahaffey house for the win wish
us luck
good uh good luck
as says
my mom was a teacher in california
teachers who claimed to care would pass
kids quote push the problem to someone
else
would get fifth graders who had no
schooling and spoke no english unions
are scum
yeah well
debbie
gary farah says miss mcardle i believe
that oregon legalized heroin but it's
backfiring this is why we have fentanyl
in the u.s because the mexican cartels
were forced to change their strategy to
pull a profit
there's a little more to that story
we should make cartels not legal oh wait
i i heard they just arrested like this
cartel and like all over the country
maryland and washington all that stuff
yeah
stephen wise says fbi document leaked
targeting 2a flying the gadsden flag and
caps etc search project veritas mve
militia violent extremists i saw this
it's crazy
when they're when they're saying the
gads didn't flag as extremist i'm like
virginia issues those license plates
yeah
that's crazy that's that's a bumper
sticker you can buy on amazon that's so
crazy we have it
like there's a skateboard pro
skateboarder who has painted his mini
ramp with the gadsden flag on it it's
like it just means leave me alone yeah i
have a bunch of them it's normal we made
little patches that say don't snake me
bro it's a skateboarding thing like when
you cut someone off and jump your turn
yep yeah
don't snake me bro
we got to get those boards made
we're trying to
i shouldn't say trying we are working
towards launching a skate shop the good
news is the new facility has started
construction oh that's awesome yeah
so hopefully they say two weeks until
the building's done then the internals
insulation hvac the studio building can
you share where that's where that's at
in west virginia oh cool yeah so i mean
it's not that far away it's just we have
way more space so we're gonna have a big
acreage and then we have chicken city
here and then we have cocktown there are
there a lot of skateboarders in west
virginia no okay because i was at a
libertarian party event there earlier
this year and we were at a bike shop
and it was not
it was a little more you know like x
games than than your typical bike shop i
thought it was interesting so there's
some sort of well if it was like
like bmx yeah bike stuff then they're
doing tricks and if if it was like a
road bike yeah no it was like bmx stuff
yeah it was interesting because there's
clearly an appetite for that sort of
culture in west virginia oh yeah
everywhere everywhere we're excited i
was told by these big companies if you
build it they will come
so like we're putting together this big
in in indoor skate park for we're gonna
be filming we're gonna create a channel
called free damastan where we film
action sport exploits and stuff and i've
already got a bunch of pros that are
interested in coming out which is really
cool from all different disciplines
scooting
bikes blades skateboarding so we're
gonna we're gonna have really fun stuff
jumping through flaming hoops and things
like that sounds amazing yeah airbags
foam pits we're building a lateral auto
belay it's called you know what an auto
belay is
when you're rock climbing you have a
delay an auto belay just
you just go down slowly automatically a
lateral one can roll on a track
so you can go full speed launch in the
air and then go super high and slowly
lower down oh very nice yeah so it's for
just like for fun for fun yeah we're
gonna do funny stuff with it didn't they
have a push to get rid of their state
income tax they're doing it right now so
they're still trying hey man west
virginia i knew it was gonna be a good
place for business education freedom
business freedom the governor says he
wants to cut income tax by like he he
wants to
cut it down and eventually eliminate all
together but it's the state legislature
that's blocking yes the governor is like
but he's i think he's a billionaire what
so it's like three-quarters majority
republicans in the in the house in west
virginia west virginia still has this
weird element you know yeah they have
critical race theory in their schools
they do have a weird element the there
are some libertarian candidates i can't
remember his last name right now but
they're they're actually making a lot of
ground right now in their state assembly
races
i'm looking at it more as a becoming the
house minority party
not the majority so that's the approach
i take
all right i'm gonna grab one more super
chat here and it's from brian david who
says aliens
and that's it if you haven't already my
friends would you smash that like button
subscribe to this channel share the show
with your friends head over to
timcast.com because we're going to be
talking about the latest declaration of
emergencies in two different states over
monkey box
there was a viral trend on twitter where
they said that it was airborne it is not
but we're going to talk about that and
considering the adult nature
of the story
we'll make this one uncensored you can
uh smash the like button to support the
support the show subscribe share it you
can follow us at teamcast irl you can
follow me at timcast angela do you want
to shout anything out yeah if you want
to join the libertarian party please go
to lp.org and join you can find out all
my crazy
insurgency political strategies and rage
against drag queens story hour at
patreon.com forward slash angela mcardle
right on corey yeah you can follow me on
twitter at deangeliscory and if you want
to help us at the american federation
for children to fight for education
freedom you can go to education
educationfreedompledge.com
uh thanks for coming always great to see
you guys i'm ian crossland you follow me
ian crossland.net you can uh get in
touch with me through social media that
way uh check you later
hey thanks for watching
tell me more
say peace out all right thanks for
hanging out everybody we will see you
all over at timcast.com
you